رئيس استونيا الارا كاريس سيده كاريس
بدايه ما تقييمكم حتى الان لما جرى طرحه
وتباحثه في اليوم الاول لهذا المؤتمر
الدولي لاعاده اعمار اوكرانيا بخصوص جهود
اعاده الاعمار فيها
لقد كان فقط منتصف اليوم الاول لذلك
ناقشنا مع باستطاعتنا ان نقوم به من اجل
اعاده بناء اوكرانيا بالتالي هنالك نقاط
حول اعاده الاعمار وايضا من مساله القضايا
الانسانيه الناس الذين
تركوا البلد
لتشييعهم على العوده واعاده بناء اوكرانيا
ايضا
نعم فخامه الرئيس الحديث الان عن اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا ولكن هذه الحرب
ما زالت مستمره يعني يجب ان تتوقف الحرب
حتى يكون هناك اعاده اعمار هل ترون من
خلال لقائكم مع القاده الاخرين ان هناك
افاقا لحل يوقف والحرب في اوكرانيا
اكيد يجب ان يكون هنالك حل بين سيحظى متى
سيحصل هذا لا نعرف لكننا ما هنالك الدول
نحن ايضا نقوم باجراء اشراكات من اجل
افتتاح
دار ايواء ودار حضانه ومدارس علينا ان
نبدا بهذا الجهد منذ الان وايضا هنالك
شركات ايضا التي عانت من الحربه بالتالي
انا هنا في لندن من ضمن وفد لرجال الاعمال
ايضا والشركات
ونحتاج الى شركات من المملكه المتحده من
اجل تشجيعهم على
عقود عقدي عقود عقود مشاركه من اجل اعاده
بناء اوكرانيا نعم هناك شركات منخرطه
شركات معروفه جدا منخرطه في هذه الجهود
ولكن كما قال زميلي عمليا هل يمكن تحقيق
اي مشاريع لاعاده اعمار بلد هو ما زالت
تحت القص وتحت المعارك وهناك هجوم مضاد من
هذا البلد يسعى من خلاله الى استرجاع
اراضي هل اعاده الاعمار واقعيه الان في
هذا الوقت
نعم نعم انه قانا اي وهو هذه عمليه مستمره
هذه عمليه مستمره وهنالك عدد كبير من
الشركات تقوم وبدات
كما تعرفون ان الحرب لا تشمل كل المناطق
في اوكرانيا باستطاعتنا العمل في المناطق
القريبه ملكيه مثلا
ما هو الدور الذي تقومون به اتحدث
كاستونيا ما هو دور استونيا في هذا
المؤتمر
لدينا عده شركات تعمل سويه مع الحكومه
الاوكرانيه وبالتاكيد نحن نعتبر نفسنا
بلدا رقميا وقمنا
بانظمه
جعلي انظمه الحكومه رقميه واكثر شفافيه
بالتالي هذه الانظمه بدات بدانا بالعمل
بها وتاسيس لها في اوكرانيا وخاصه في
مساله هذه البرامج والمشاريع الرقميه رئيس
وزراء اوكرانيا كان قد مدح دوركم في مساله
اعاده الاعمال وقال انستونيا اول من قام
بعمليه اعاده الاعمار فعليا وكذلك استوني
طورت اليه لمصادره الاموال الروسيه بهدف
استثمارها في هذه العمليه اين وصلت جهودكم
في هذا السياق
بالتاكيد من المهم جدا ان تكون روسيا
مسؤوله وتدفع تتحمل مسؤوليتها عن هذا
الامر ولكن الامر لا يتعلق
بمساله مصادره ما نقوم به هو عمليه
قانونيه
[موسيقى]
في نحن في هذا المؤتمر روسيا غير
حاضره نحن نناقشه هنا مع شركائنا
واصدقائنا حول اعادته بناء اوكرانيا هذا
هو هدف
المؤتمر والمؤتمر الثاني من المهم جدا ان
يبدا الحلفاء والشركاء في هذه العمليه
وبعد انتهاء الحرب سيكون هنالك حديث اخر
نعم قلت في بدايه جوابك الاول ان هو منتصف
اليوم الاول فقط من هذا المؤتمر وبالتالي
لم تنتهوا بعد من طرح هذه يعني كل جوانب
هذه المساله مساله اعاده الاعمار ولكن هل
لمستم استعدادا كافيا من المشاركين في
المؤتمر لجمع الدعم الكافي لاعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا يعني انطباعك الاولي حول هذه
المساله حتى الان
انطباعي
نحن
مقتنعون تماما نحن ندعم اوكرانيا ويجب ان
نبدا باعاده اعمار اوكرانيا سويه لم اسمع
اي شركه او اي سياسيين يقول غير ذلك نعم
مؤتمر قد بدا اليوم وهنالك ايضا سيكون
هنالك نقاش لخمسه عشره لجنه بالتالي علينا
ان ننتظر ربما يوم غدا لنرى ما هي نتيجه
هذه النقاشات بعد هذا المؤتمر الان ما هي
الخطوه المقبله دائما في سياق الحديث عن
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
ستكون بعدتي البناء والاستمرار بهذا الامر
ان يكون هنالك حلول مستدامه ورقميه
وحقيقيه وواقعيه هذا هو الطريق لبناء
اوكرانيا الجديده شكرا جزيلا لك كان ذلك
من لندن من مؤتمر دعم اوكرانيا واعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا من الرئيس
الاستونيس شكرا جزيلا لك فخامه الرئيس